en lo referente a lo que el régimen
talibán dice incorporar la postura de la
mujer dentro de lo que viene a ser su
administración es justo lo que decía ya
el alto comisionado importante
comisionado de derechos humanos de
naciones unidas se recibe con
escepticismo por el pasado por supuesto
pero sobre todo por hechos es decir nos
gustaba siempre intentar ver las
demostraciones por parte del régimen
talibán lo que se ha visto es que
efectivamente la imposición de la sharía
desde la manera tan rigorista que los
talibanes la entienden donde las mujeres
tienen que vestir con el burka donde las
niñas no pueden salir tienen que salir
de la escuela de los diez años y hasta
pueden casarse antes o ya una vez hayan
salido de la escuela y ponerse a
trabajar en algunos casos depende de qué
tipo de trabajos
deja deja mucho entre entrever ese tipo
de dualidad frente al hecho de que la
mujer vaya a estar en la administración
afgana qué tipo de mujer
qué tipo de desarrollo de la mujer se va
a permitir dentro del país es algo muy
importante
personalmente y desde un punto de vista
a futuro lo que se suele entender por
perspectiva es una estrategia de
propaganda es decir es una forma de
entrar en el poder es una forma de
consolidarse con promesas que habrá que
ver si tan reales son como ellos dicen
pero personalmente hice un han
demostrado es muy difícil hablemos de
esa consolidación porque estas
declaraciones del talibán han sido
interpretadas como señales positivas en
países como rusia y también turquía que
tanta aceptación tendrá este gobierno
talibán en la comunidad internacional
bueno efectivamente los líderes o las
grandes potencias regionales va a ser
turquía pakistán china rusia irán y
qatar ya han reconocido al régimen
talibán ha querido nombrar todas porque
es muy anecdótico que son países que
tienen también en general buenas
relaciones entre ellos
en este sentido a nivel internacional se
está empezando a ver con mucho
escepticismo porque la postura de eeuu
ha llegado hasta decirse que puede que
eeuu para que se haga una transición
pacífica y no se repitan errores del
pasado ni derramamientos de sangre
puedan llegar a reconocer al régimen
talibán para que no se produzca por
ejemplo un colapso de refugiados esto no
tiene ningún no tiene ni pies ni cabeza
la realidad es que estamos hablando de
un grupo armado que sigue teniendo lazos
con grupos terroristas como es al qaeda
y eso no va a cambiar tocaba un punto
muy importante y es el de los refugiados
que podemos esperar en medio de esta
crisis humanitaria en las próximas
semanas hay especial preocupación por
quienes huyen del país y por una nueva
posible crisis de refugiados con la que
europa dice que no está lista para poder
lidiar con ello
efectivamente desde europa es muy
complicado lidiar con esta crisis y al
final anteriormente comentábamos ustedes
en el noticiero que bueno que los
republicanos atacaban a bailén esta
forma tan desastrosa la única otra forma
de haber hecho esto hubiera sido hacerlo
más paulatinamente durante el tiempo y
pero los refugiados hubiesen salido
igualmente entonces europa sigue sin
estar
dispuesta no dispuesta tanto sino más
que nada preparada los países de
alrededor como es irán como es pakistán
o como serán turquía que serán los
principales receptores de refugiados los
van a aceptar muy probablemente pero no
van a poder tampoco
asimilar esta es este gran volumen de
miles de millones de millones de
personas que seguramente intenten salir
y aquí hay que entender otro factor
fundamental en cuanto a los refugiados
los que puedan permitirse llegar a
pagarse un viaje como hemos visto con la
crisis de refugiados sirios
y hasta hasta europa y los refugiados
que no puedan llegar y que tengan que
vivir en unas condiciones infrahumanas
porque prefieren eso a tener que estar
bajo el yugo de líbano
complicada la situación en afganistán
amén gracias por estar aquí con nosotros
en france 24 que tengo usted un feliz
resto de día